As you can see, I have a search page open
on my phone. Let's go to Timeline and record a
trace. Okay. Now, let's take a look at what we
have here. First, notice that we see an event for
the HTML Request. Then, the server responds and we get
the Response event. From there, the HTML is streaming in
and the parse is processing each chunk, by following the
same steps we just described. Tokenizing the data, converting tokens
into nodes, and building a [UNKNOWN].
>> Hm. Nice. So the timeline gives us a pretty low
level view into what the browser's doing as it loads a page.
>> Yes, exactly. And it can be a bit overwhelming at first. There's a lot of
different events in here. But don't worry, we're
going to cover most of them. That said, I think
it's a good idea for you to just try and record a few different traces on, on
your own. Pick a couple of favorite sites,
record a few traces. See if you can spot
some interesting patterns. Once you're done,
click this checkbox, to hit continue.